hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Q&A video for everything from
Episode two there's some questions about
Episode three because of the teaser so
we'll dress all that stuff just careful
for spoilers if you're not caught up
there are a couple big things that we'll
be talking about this week specifically
R plus L equals J Tower of joy Lyanna
Stark a lot of that will be dealt with
in episode 3 so expect a whole bunch of
that stuff later this week it's gonna be
a lot of fun I've already done a couple
videos explaining those things so I'll
put links in the description but I
haven't watched those in a while so I'll
have to check them out to see if there's
anything I left out so Jon Snow coming
back is really just tip of the iceberg
it's gonna be so much fun the next
couple of weeks here we go to questions
couple of Benjen questions to start
things off Raphael asks do you think
that the Knights came could be Benjen
Stark well we saw him in that flashback
there was like a you know mini Benjen so
I think that they wouldn't do that if
they weren't intending to show him again
a lot of you picked up on the ringing
the bell line that John said to Ollie as
if they were proceeding Jon Snow coming
back by having another character speak
his lines earlier in the episode so
there's a whole lot more that's going on
in that Blache back scene one they're
teeing up an explainer for how Hodor
became Hodor and we'll talk about that
later in this video
but they're teeing up Lyanna stark so I
think they're also teeing up a benjin
reveal I do think he's still alive but
the only way he's the night's king is if
they've recast Benjen stark is another
actor because this actor most definitely
not joseph malli he's the actor that
played benjin in season 1 but there have
been a whole lot of people on the show
that had been recast so it is totally
possible but I would be really
disappointed if they didn't get that
original actor to come back so for now
that's why I don't think that he's the
night's king because I don't think that
they've recast the actor I think that's
the only way the night's king explainer
works george RR martin also debunked the
Benjen cold hands theory a long long
time ago so benjin's still alive I have
a feeling that we'll find him through
brans storyline because right now he's
the only protagonist this north of the
wall next question Cayley mundo asks
wonder what made benjin take the black
but there's actually two theories one
the simple one is that he was just so
low on the totem pole of inheritance
that his prospects weren't that great so
he's like okay I'll go take the black
like a lot of people who are third or
fourth sons but the other theory is
Lyanna stark related it's a bit of a
tinfoil theory but it's possible that
benjin knows that Jon Snow is the son of
Rhaegar Targaryen and
Oh Stark and just to protect that secret
to prevent someone from trying to get it
out of them he took the black because
the rest of the kingdom would just
forget about him up at the wall bit of a
tinfoil follow-up to that lyanna stark's
stuff but Punk ster asks sneaking
suspicion that Hodor was willingly
silence due to the secret he holds which
is our plus l equals j i mean i would be
afraid if Hodor was part of that tower
of joy flashback because that's so far
off book that it would be like a huge
change when I saw the Hodor scene and
then I saw the extended trailer for
episode three where you see like the one
guard fighting all the people in
northern armor I was like oh man how
much are they gonna change this from the
books Arthur Dayne who's super badass so
it's possible that they could have gone
way off book in this dual wielder who
just a total badass he is Arthur Dayne
in a slightly older version of Hodor was
part of that party that went with Ned
Stark to rescue Liana and he was injured
but that's kind of an extreme
interpretation it's totally possible
that he just found out some other way
and then someone wanted to silence him
but very clearly he seems like a really
innocent person in the past so I think
the actual explanation that the show
goes with will be tied to some noble
sacrifice that he made next question
Gabriel asks I was wanting John
resurrection in episode 5 like in a big
fire walking out a bit unburned or
something like that maybe even given
Longclaw sword starts glowing red so
yeah you want like the azure 'hi --hi is
definitely a Targaryen interpretation of
his resurrection I think that's the
exact reason why they didn't do that one
of the biggest theories about why they
didn't do Lady Stoneheart
earlier in the series like during season
4 season 5 is because it would have
tipped the hat to what's going on with
Jon Snow in episode 2 like if you
witness a start coming back from the
dead it suddenly makes Jon Snow coming
back that less special it's that less of
a surprise so I think they're saving the
big Jon Snow Targaryen reveal for Tower
of joy they want that to come first but
even though I do think that he's a
Targaryen I mean he's the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen so he's half Targaryen I don't
think they're gonna be super literal
with the Ozora highest stuff I think
he's just gonna be a leader he'll be a
badass if necessary he'll lay down his
life a lot of people have been making
Jesus jokes like he came back from the
dead just like Jesus he'll take all the
sins of the kingdom and then die again
during the war for the dawn I would be
very surprised if he ended up on the
Iron Throne
I think he and Daenerys are around too
the kingdom and bind the world against
the force of the others like the forces
of man versus the others so you can't
really get to that point til Daenerys
gets to Westeros the John is slowly
uniting the north
you have the Nights Watch and the
wildlings that'll slowly come together
they used to hate each other I think the
same thing will happen all over Westeros
and then Daenerys will arrive and then
they'll all come together BAM big war
for the dawn but we're really just at
the beginning of that there's still two
more seasons remember next question
monkey bomb-squad asks now I forgive
Melisandre for burning Stannis's
daughter so do the rest of us Carice van
Houten was actually a saint you know
like hurter predation of this really old
version of Melisandre if she's 400 years
old what's a little child's life to
someone who's that old when it was
happening we're all screaming were
horrified but if you've lived for 400
years think about how many people you've
watched live and die so that's why it
was so easy for her to burn this child
without any remorse if you thought that
she had a smug look on her face in the
first couple of seasons just wait till
she finds out that Jon Snow came back
and think about what that's gonna do to
her going forward
she'll probably feel invincible next
question no skills asks not sure if it's
been mentioned on the show but a person
loses part of their self when their
resurrected do you think that Jon will
change at all deaf yeah definitely I
think that he'll be a little disoriented
at first like he won't know what's
happened and then after that he'll just
be a slightly more stannis version of
himself if you thought that he was
withdrawn before boy what's gonna happen
now
practically I think that he's just gonna
come away seeming more purpose-driven
like he won't sit around wondering what
the right thing to do is he'll just be
like all right this is what we're doing
this is how it's gonna happen let's do
it no more [ __ ] so it'll be a little
bit more like Stannis like Stannis was
absolutely sure of his cause I think Jon
Snow will be a little bit more like that
next question hot hub asks do you think
that the red gods powers only work when
priests lose their faith in them like
Thoreau Samir mentioned how he first
resurrected beric Dondarrion and the
same thing happened when Melisandre lost
her faith no I mean I think that it's
people that are really important come
back you really have to believe that
there is a red God there's like some
Supreme intelligence
at play so like an evil character kicks
somebody important off the board beric
Dondarrion gets kicked off the board by
the mountain the red God recognizes that
someday he will be very important to
Arya Stark in the Hound
so he says this cannot be and he does
the Lord of the Rings Gandalf thing
where he gets
back onto the board cut to Jon Snow very
important figure in rallying the kingdom
against the great other teamollie stabs
him off the game board and then the red
God says again you know this cannot be
and kicks him back onto the board I
really like the idea of like the
universe selecting its champions and
like it recognizes beric Dondarrion Jon
Snow other characters in the books like
Lady Stoneheart those are its champions
so it kicks them back onto the board
Starks are in play again next question
annie asks isn't lyanna stark's supposed
to be younger than brandon and Ned why
are they going with that yeah a lot
people were confused because in the
books she's supposed to be younger but
she seems older on the TV show they
might be using the same actress for a
tower of joy flashback and that's why
they wanted to go older because it's
really hard to like age someone up that
looks like they're 8 years old
next question though cancerous asks in
the episode 3 preview who do you think
the gift is for Ramsay I think I think
we're probably all in agreement that
it's Rickon Stark do you like games
little man if you thought that they age
Leon a stark up this is what the actor
who played Rickon looks like now so I'll
be interested to see if they recast the
role I don't know if he was seen on set
but I do think that this is where we'll
see Rick and and OSHA again through
house umber because it's house Karstark
house number they're like we have a gift
for you there's a lot of weirdness going
on between the books in the show I think
they've changed a couple of things with
that storyline so so when we do get that
episode I'll try to explain what the
exact changes were next question your
name is the symbol so I don't know how
to pronounce that but let's say what if
Jon Snow's mine was transferred into
ghosts
like what if he Ward into ghosts and
what we saw was a surprise ghost waking
up in Jon's body I I don't think that
that's what happened but what you're
talking about is Jon being a warg he is
a warg George are Martin has confirmed
that all the star children have wolf
dreams which means that they have the
ability to work but that doesn't
guarantee that all them are gonna be
using that ability in a conscious way
usually when you talk about wolf Dreams
it's an unconscious thing I think if
anybody's gonna be working besides brand
it'll probably be Arya but it would be
really awesome like if Bram see snow is
gonna go down if the dire wolves take
him down you know like Ramsay SiC the
hounds on Walda what if Ramsay also went
down and the pack of dogs I mean they'd
be dire wolf so they're not dogs but you
get the metaphor he would be really
badass if Santa were the ones who work
all those dire wolves onto Ramsay but
I'm totally not expecting that to happen
what I'm really hoping she does is she
the one to order Ramsey's death and she
has him flayed so moving on there were a
couple other like just general questions
that people had like where's
Littlefinger all the characters that we
haven't seen yet like Samwell and Gilly
we'll probably see in episode 3 so by
episode 3 most of the main cast will be
back there are still a couple characters
a couple big characters that are coming
back that might not happen till later in
the series if you remember what Ian
McShane said I think I made a couple
videos about that then you know what I'm
talking about
giveaway time though congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner
Andrew Thorpe you win a $20 Amazon gift
card just be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details that's just on
the about page new round will start
whenever I post my next bonus video most
of this week like I said is going to be
devoted to talking about R + L equals J
Tower of joy Lyanna Stark Rhaegar
Targaryen stuff it is gonna be so much
fun and I am kind of expecting them to
change the Tower of joy battle scene
from what it was in the books so they
might end up mixing and matching a
couple people if you're a book reader
just prepare yourself for that sorry I'd
like to say sorry
while you guys wait for my next video
you can click here to learn more about
lyanna stark's history and you can click
here for my episode 2 video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you